um
in the council chamber today and those
on live stream
to the extraordinary infrastructure
meeting 29th
march 2021
right we're going to start with
apologies
and i have them from councillor abbott
and from lindsay mckenzie uh
his is here
if someone please move those apologies
counselor sopa secondary council lewis
put the motion all those in favor
right first interest register i've had
no updates
and nothing to declare so we'll move on
to the first item which is the long term
plan asset long term plan
asset and activity plans now rhiannon
welcome
thank you chair um just to take the
report as read these
are the last plans for the committee to
receive
ahead of consultation um the property
or building asset plan rather
obviously needed the strategic project
process to complete
and also the housing consultation um and
that's why you're receiving these plans
now
okay right so with the recommendations
quite straightforward that we confirm
the
plans and they are the draft property
asset plan the draft housing care
activity plan
and the draft public toilets activity
plan
i'm going to open it up for discussion
if anyone has anything to say before i
remove this
no okay can i please have someone move
that
we adopt please thank you counselor
crack at secretary councillor sopa put
the motion all those in favor
all right right we move now to
the hearings for the regional public
transport plan
so we'll just take that report as read
there are a couple of things to note so
with the regional public transport plan
uh these submission process have been um
undertaken by environment southland
the submissions opened on the 16th of
march and are closing on the top of
april we have so far received
three submissions and of those three
one person wants to be heard
hearings for this consultation will take
place on the 27th of april
at 11 am so the key thing today
is to seek nominations for
a um hearing panel for those hearings of
three councillors
so we already have the chair councillor
pohinger
and we need two more but just as a side
we have a long-term plan engagement
event happening on that same day
which uh councillors amongst and and
sopa
uh will be attending so if we could have
two
other councillors not them m2
thanks georgia i'll just ask the
committee who who would like to be on
this hearing panel we've got
three submissions did you say that's
correct yeah at this moment
council ludlow and oh councillor skill
i'll put you down as a backup um council
lewis just in case
right so um i've had uh the name
spotforwarder of council ludlow
councillor skelt
i'm going to move that they be the two
hearings panel members that join me can
i have a second please
with council lewis as the backup
councillor kit and councillor craic at
second did i put the motion on those in
favor
okay and that's that part done
but we have to received the report which
we've done
and we have to note uh the hearings for
the regional land
transport plan and that the southland
regional
regional public transport plan which is
the one that we're doing here
so i'm going to put those all again as
one lot
i'll move that out of a second to please
counselor soap and thank you put motion
all those in favor
great that moves us on now to the
roading and
traffic bylaw review
and speak to that
welcome russell i get the loach here you
pop up
thanks mr chairman um
this is the bylaw revisiting which which
we
have head out to public consultation
between november and
9th of december last year we had 12 12
submissions
and after discussion with some of those
people no one wished to be heard
most of the submissions that we received
were predominantly
focused around i guess amending the
speed and after some consultation with
nzta
they've said that we need to directly
consult on speed
which we propose to do through the
middle part of this year
so the changes that we're proposing to
the previous bylaw
through this consultation process are
relatively minor
and we're proposing this reading and
traffic bylaw
will be operation or operative from the
first of july
this year coming and in recommendation
five it is a recommendation to council
which seeks for council to
adopt the bylaw so thanks very much mr
children
it's noted in uh recommendation six that
obviously it's the door is still open
to change uh things at a later time
is that correct correct mr chairman you
certainly
can with a speed by law and it's likely
that we will
look to introduce a specific bylaw
relating to speed because speeders seems
to be one of a
certainly an area where the community
has lots of interest and there's lots of
change
to i guess occur in the wider context
right okay any discussion counselors
all right quite a lot oh yes counselor
oh sorry
uh i was just going to say there's no
questions i was going to say i was
having to remove the
recommendations well it seems to be no
question so
i'll accept that you move these
recommendations second to place
thank you councillor skel we'll put
those
six recommendations all those in favor
against that is carried that moves us on
to the parking control
bylaw review
russell thanks mr chairman this and this
this is a
another one of the i guess the important
roading bylaws that
that i have and this is the one that
actually sets um
the parking restrictions and parking or
the use of parking in the city so that
our
enforcement team can keep the traffic
moving
once again we consulted between the 10th
of november and and the 9th of december
we had 9 submissions and again no one
wishes to be heard
the bylaw is proposed to be operative
from the first
first of july the report sets out the
areas where we see
the significant i guess the changes from
the
current bylaw which are there to help
highlight those changes
there are some thoughts a little bit um
with our new equipment and how we'll go
about it so that's hopefully reasonably
self-explanatory
i do think we will have to probably
revisit this bylaw
as the city centre changes and we will
have to
i guess address changes in the
street by street parking so there is an
opportunity and in the report there are
there is a table of a number of minor
amendments that i need to bring
to get approved so that the plans can be
updated which are attached to the back
of the bylaw
right any discussion anyone here
okay one question oh sorry counselor
cricket here we go
got a question um the question was
regarding
um and i've had to read through this but
i may have missed it is the
hours where the bylaw operates you know
where it kicks in or is it going to be a
24 7.
just i was just thinking of when people
go out at evening
and require perhaps a longer
parking time you know for restaurants or
whatever as opposed to your
normal nine til five shopping
um i would need to check but i would
have expected the
bylaw to have been operative
monday to friday and during business
hours and on saturday mornings but i
need to is that something that we have
to write down just in case of
interpretation
you know like do we have to include it
and uh
i would need to check but um it should
be stated i would agree
yeah no i had a bit of a look but i just
couldn't find it yeah
sorry uh councillor cracker um thank you
mr chair
i'm really pleased to see these
amendments come forward it's um
i think that they'll offer a lot of
convenience with the new kiosks
in the center city i mean i'm sure that
most of our community has experienced
this type of technology in other regions
um some of those advantages being that
if you've got the app
and you could be at work or you could be
out shopping and decide that you
actually want to stay in town a little
bit longer than
than you currently are and then use that
app to
up your time period or period of paid
parking without having to return to your
vehicle
it also gives us a lot more control
where we can extend
payment periods or a time that you could
spend parking in town or i have
parking free holidays or all sorts of
things so
i'm really pleased to see this i am
happy to
move the recommendations as they stand
thank you um russell
um i just can't identify it but we could
i can report
i guess to council or we could
consider i think i just would like the
opportunity to perhaps just check and
come back
i just think it's one of these critical
ones where you actually know when it
when it kicks in and not you don't get
sort of called out at
seven o'clock if you're dining at six
and those are just
sort of occurred to me the other
question was the usually 9am
kiosk i believe that's correct like at
the moment our existing meters have
have it on and our kiosks will actually
have
the applicable times and just as they
noted in the
in the bylaw the other question
was regarding the app it did say that
hopefully the app would be like a com
like one that may be abused around the
place so that
you know we weren't what was it
other districts here so mr chairman at
the moment we have a proposal for
uh received a proposal for the kiosks
and the app
and at the moment we're reviewing and
assessing those
we would certainly be looking to have an
app that is um
consistent with others that you don't
have to have
three different apps if you wanted to
need and one in queenstown i know that i
think wellington has six different
applicable ones but we would ideally
only have one
that would actually be able to be used
so no that's that's good
okay so we've had these moved by
councillor crackit
um seconded by councillor where i take
it or are you wanting to i
i am second happily but i just wanted to
also
um add that while it may sound very
old-school
i am pleased that coins can still be
utilized as a payment option because i'm
well aware
and have had comments from a number of
elderly people on that very question
so i think it's good that we are moving
with the times but also recognise that
we have
some members of the population who will
be happier to
know that coins are still available
okay so now for the comments we have the
four
recommendations in front of us uh like
put the motion all those in favor
against is carried
and i would uh like to
call the meeting over thank you for
participating
are we still streaming live or do we
adjourn for the next meeting
you've closed the meetings
yeah i realized that but you don't do um
[Laughter]
which of these
apparently a silver needle is quite good
um
um
as entire
good afternoon your worship councillors
staff member of the public members of
the public and the press
i'll declare this uh extraordinary
meeting of performance policy and
partnerships open
we have apologies as per previous from
councillor abbott and also lindsey
mckenzie if somebody would like to move
councillor lewis seconded councillor
pottinger
also to note that uh andy burns may from
audit may zoom in
at some point as well uh so we've got
the apologies moved in second
i'll put the motion all in favor against
carried first up on a full house
we won't set a uh set of tests at the
end of it because um i appreciate the
amount of reading
uh that sits in here but of course most
of this has been before
us before
i was pretty tired by the time i got to
halfway through the fees
and um charges and then realized of
course that
i had noted these before that was a late
uh late friday night we've got the free
fees and charges schedule as proposed
for 2122
here rhiannon uh is there anything you'd
like to add in speaking to your report
thank you chair i'll take the report as
read um
this is the fees and charges scheduled
for consultation
um consultation will take place
alongside the long-term plan
just to remind counsellors that you made
a decision last year when selling the
fees and charges to increase the
professional um charge out rates um
which are used for some services known
as the corporate fees across
three years so that has been taken into
account with this
setting of the fees and charges for this
year um
the change is proposed or outlined in
summary
for the substantial changes for each
area um
and just to say we're proposing removing
the airport fees and charges as it's the
cco there is no requirement to consult
on these
fees and charges at this time thanks
rhiannon
two recommendations is the remover
happy to move councillor soper seconded
councillor eminson
it's open for questions counselor clark
sorry mr chair um
in on page 12 of now records it says the
animal services have no
changes and yet when i look at page 21
there's an increase for the registration
of working dogs it goes from 35
up to 150 so that just
raises a flag i guess
sorry cats are you talking about animal
services yes animals
dog control fees registration so it says
the 20 21
fee is 34 currently 35 which is low for
working dogs
and this proposal goes up to 150.
um which is higher than that's that's
puts it on a level with menacing and
dangerous dogs
okay that's an error then in that cover
report
so apologies for that that's right so
that should remain
as it was so no the schedule is correct
so it will be my summary i probably
should have written no changes other
than working dogs
so that came counselor clark
the begs another question i guess that
it seems to me that we've gone from a
situation where a working dog was
rested at a much lower rate than a
residential dog
and we've pushed that up and like to
have some logic for that
given it's at the same rate as what we
would charge for a menacing or dangerous
dog which is quite a bit of work for us
just from memory before i ask for an
answer i think
there is a set fee for a maximum number
of dogs as well
uh five or more i think from memory
which which caps it um
who would like to handle this rhiannon
or darren
i'll refer this to darren
and i'd like to understand as
the discussion has gone through the
shift from 35
for a week to 150
it does seem to be rather
you're gonna have to take that away and
come back rather swiftly because we're
gonna confirm them at the following
meeting
thanks thanks councillor clark any other
points you wish to raise
well there's just one other quick uh
thing yeah sorry i'll still with
councillor clark just choose
anything else thank you sorry now
counselor
i was just going to say the additional
late fee after the first september goes
from 25 percent of registration
to 50 assuming that's an increase as
well
yes and that's to encourage people to
register on time
all right that's just that i thought
there's no changes to it
um if if you look at page
12 of your agenda in the summary table
it says a 50 late fee for dog
registration is proposed
after first of september to replace the
earlier fee and this is to bring council
into line with fees set by south and
district in gall district
that's the reason put forward by the
animal services team
and that's what they're recommending
counselor cricket um thank you mr chair
um it's
i think it's worth noting that these
fees and charges the schedule um
that has been put forward to us is again
to
uh go out concurrently for consultation
uh any feedback that we do have on
animal
services or any discrepancies and
differences and fees and charges i
believe will come out in the wash with
consultation
and we'll hear from our community i'm
comfortable with
hopefully getting an answer from animal
services for from
through uh darren that we again ask what
our community's opinion is on our
fees and charges settings and go forward
with consultation
thanks councillor if there are no other
comments i'm prepared to leave this one
just sitting on the table bearing in
mind that we're going to confirm this in
the in the meeting that follows so i'll
give
darren a chance to seek some
clarification and come back to us
we've got a weight of other ones to get
through so
hopefully that'll buy him some time
counselors are you happy
comfortable enough with that yeah thanks
so that takes us through to the uh
supplementary materials for consultation
there's um one or two
in fact from memory i think it's the
first time we've managed to get through
the entire alphabet on one of the points
which is uh the
the second point um
so it was a task well well well done
thanks for the reason if that
were there other ambitions you'd care to
share with me or
for the remainder of the report
um again i'll take this report as read
and i think in this case
that really is the case because most of
these materials counselors you will have
received before you're receiving them
all again
so that you can have the absolute final
version and see the packaging materials
together
as the report notes these are all the
supplementary materials for the
consultation
the majority of these will be on the
website roadmap to renewal which will
launch
when we launch consultation um
obviously we've been through the order
process now and i see that andy has just
joined
the meeting and so there are some small
changes that have been made
to activity plans and asset plans
some of the financial materials
that i've put up here all of those noted
under 0.2 there are not
substantial changes so they're provided
again for your reference
i've pointed you to the three areas
are where you may want to focus on the
more substantial
substantive changes as a result of audit
so under recommendation poor
and that's the financial strategy where
there's been a change to some wedding
around a dat and michael may wish to
speak more
to that or he may not he does not
um the key assumptions document where
there have been some changes as a result
of the audit process
to reflect really taking a completionist
approach
i guess so we've included some new
assumptions around cobit 19 and the
potential implications for rates income
asset life investment property and
forestry
capital program delivery asset
revaluation
and interest rates and some changes to
the
risk of uncertainty so i think that's
just important to note when it comes to
assumptions that they are of course
just that they are assumptions around
forecasting which are used for modeling
they are not in any way looking into a
crystal ball and knowing what the future
is going to hold
as a general principle we've taken a
conservative approach
in order that the finance team when
building the budget were able to
put together something that the
community could be sure
was was built in that conservative
manner so that covers off the key
assumptions
and then the third element which has
been revised is the revenue and finance
policy
so that's just to note that we're now
including information within that policy
that will enable the public to see the
difference
between the proposed rating approach
and the existing rating approach if the
revenue and
finance policy was not to be updated so
this provides a greater amount of
information
for the public and that is noted as well
in the consultation document
um so that's all i'll say to this report
thanks rhianna so councillors we have uh
four recommendations which include a
reasonable number of subset of other
recommendations
um as the remover and the secondary for
the recommendations
i'm happy to move those councillor
emerson and councillor partinger
it's open for questions or comments at
this point bearing in mind that this
is the draft that goes out for
consultation shortly
uh there's still a process whereby we
want to
seek feedback we talked at the workshop
the other day how we would like to
encourage as many people as possible
to submit so if you have any feedback
on what's contained in the full
recommendations
now's the time
i supported going out to
consultation
thank you your worship councillor clark
um
just like to backtrack a little bit onto
the previous
very long list of uh um in
in five the material for consultational
supplementary i just got some questions
here if you'd
allow that absolutely okay um
on page one five seven three
which is the significance and engagement
draft policy
from my recall of the last one that we
had i think we had
in there a monetary criteria as well and
it seems to be
not there in this draft so i wonder
whether somebody with a bit more
experience
me could help me with that so previously
it had a dollar amount if a project was
over a dollar amount you had to sort of
go out and consult
so and it seems that that's gone so
somebody called a comment on that just
give you a chance to
just trying to find the page sorry oh
sorry um
yeah just throw yourself the chair
um counselor you're
possibly right that it was there
previously um i'll have to double check
that myself
um just in relation to a mission there
um we have had a look in in relation to
some changes that have gone through
um around significance policy um
across loca uh the local government and
government network
network recently um but i have to say i
will ha
will have to have another look to double
check to see if we should bring that
back in
thank you answer that question oh yeah
i've got several thank you and page 1
1609 and it refers to us now having a
critical rating of double a
plus previously double a minus is that
is that correct and so that's a real
plus
terrible but that's good that we've got
we've got to there
um on
page one six one zero where it talks
about cash investment and
the sets of the issue of what is net
debt
my recollection of the risk insurance
meeting we just
recently had we got a treasury report
initial interim treasury report and my
recollection was that the amount of
investment we had was about 50 million
dollars not 40.
i don't have that at hand but i did do a
quick
tally up on the day
yes please thanks smoking through
yourself chair
yes the net debt does change between
investments to change between times
we've had the repayment occurring in
relation to
council decision just recently in
relation to
holco so we've had some movement in the
investment and net depth position from
that perspective
thank you um on page one six
double one it talks about um
this council imposing um rate increase
limits
of 7.5 and i just wonder michael how
that will fit with the
current realignment of the rates that
we're doing that's going to push about
13 or 14 of our rate payers into 10
plus sort of doesn't quite align with
that
yes for yourself the chair the 7.5
um cap that's been placed within that
policy
benchmark is is across
the entire um
rates increase for the entire um
city from that perspective it's not a
per property assessment
that takes into many factors and has a
lot of
variability in relation to those
increases that's
through the consultation i think we've
got something there for people to see
two other quick things on page one six
one two
it talks about two commercial properties
and it lists don street but it seems to
be silent on the ro farm so whether
that's just a typo
because normally those two would be
clustered together
uh through self chair that is correct we
have um only listed the one
at this point as an example we would be
possible to add the other one
if so desired and the final question
um is on 1628
which continues to talk about the um
need to uh annually review the forestry
assets and i just wonder whether that's
still appropriate given
where we're going with the forestry
assets and
at this point we still need to keep
forestry um
revaluations in there as as a
requirement if we have forestry from
that perspective going forward at this
point there is none in the plan
from recent decisions it doesn't take
into account the forestry that sits with
parks and reserves
it does but we don't have any
forest per se apart from those that are
already in here
parks and recreation services
comfortable with that thank you thanks
councillor partner um just continuing
the forestry thing
um the ones at sandy point are
managed in a commercial way they are
um they are felled and then they are
replanted so it's more than
it's more than a than thinking about
queen's park and chopping down trees
that are about to fall over
um it's my belief that the sandy point
arrangement
is a commercial operation and uh we'll
we'll continue that way
and i guess it's seen i mean it's not as
probably as cyclic as
as a full commercial arrangement where
there will be gaps between filling and
then
um but but i would see it as a full
commercial operation just as
a true investment
otherwise with our carbon credits and
everything would be going a bit crazy
yeah
thanks for the explanation councillor
any other questions or
comments on the supplementary materials
counselor i do have on the uh
confirmation of the long-term plan is
that the appropriate type of that
uh we're not the no we're not quite
there thank you
no others if not then it's been moved
and seconded i'll put the motion
all in favor against
carriage counselors thank you for
your questions through that uh just to
confirm
uh if we go back to the fees and charges
the ongoing fee for working dog is still
70
uh 35 so that is a typo it's not an
increase to 150 it will still be
35 so therefore the only change in
animal fees
is for the late payment fee which is
signaled in
rhiannon's paper thank you mr chairman
can i ask a question regarding the
dog fees please um well
it's kind of naughty because we did go
through that before but
go ahead well i've just been looking
uh racing dogs which category do they
come under
i should know the answer to this
they're not classified as a working dog
but
from memory they
mostly fall under that um that bulk
payment so if you've got five or more
dogs there's a capped
fee so there aren't many people who hold
racing dogs for active racing that don't
have more than
than five animals
there are a few that have more than five
yeah so that's what they've got a capped
fee that they pay yeah
but from memory they are not classified
as a working dog
yeah they do get the reduced fee because
they're responsible owners
unless proved otherwise
thank you some flashbacks that i'm
having from past hearings about dog fees
which is why
that kind of still sits there okay
so if we're going back to the fees and
charges motion
uh that came forward before we were
seeking uh further clarification you've
had
that now so that motion has been moved
and seconded i'll now put that all in
favor
against carried which brings us
to the confirmation of the long term
plan
2021 2031 consultation document of
course you've got a
hard copy printed out uh andy burns has
joined us
uh from audits welcome along andy
thank you good afternoon everybody uh do
you have any comment that you'd
like to offer council in in
your observations and working through
the document with staff
okay maybe i'll keep this short i'm sure
you've got a full agenda
i mean the main observation is the audit
complete and you have with you today a
copy of the ordered opinion
that of all opinions basically says
that we've looked at the supporting
information for the consultation
document
we've considered whether it's founded on
evidence and whether it's integrated in
other words whether the infrastructure
strategy talk to financial strategies
talk to the financial model
talk to the cd and we're comfortable in
that space
we've looked at the console dates and
document itself and i have to say
it was great to get a consultation
document the start of the audit that was
really well
pulled together and prepared and
polished uh we've added to that to that
debate but it was great to get that from
the start
uh our opinion is going to have three
areas of emphasis um
all councils will have an area of
emphasis around the water reforms
an area of emphasis is simply saying
there's a level of risk
or the level of uncertainty in certain
areas of this plan
uh for all councils there's water reform
forms not too far away they'll obviously
change the face
of the planet if they go ahead so
there's no uncertainty there for
planning
and there are two specific to
invercargill
one is the level of reliance that you're
placing on external funding and so for
some of your consultation areas
i think in total you're assuming 19.2
million
across smart across rugby park and the
urban play area
so there's a level of uncertainty to
that because nothing's signed up at this
point in time
you've talked to an expert you've come
to an estimate of what you might get
but clearly if you don't get that money
there's a signal in this
consultation document that you'll go
back to consider either consider
future options or go back to the right
pair again to consult on what you want
to do
so an area of uncertainty there in terms
of external funding
and the third one is about the capital
program itself um
councils well all organizations probably
struggle to deliver a capital program
this capital program you have that
underpins this plan is particularly
ambitious
um it's kind of a step change from the
previous 2018 ltp
uh so so you're putting play into place
of pmo
another other factors to try to manage
your ability to deliver but a lot of
risk there again
around simply your ability to deliver
the capital program uh within a 10-year
period
on top of that you've got your specific
consultation areas that will obviously
have further
um you know significant to the size of
the cattle program
so it's a clean opinion and you've got
it it's there to adopt with your
consultation document
but three areas of risk uh that were
particularly highlighting in the audit
opinion itself
that will go out when it goes out when
you adopt it
thanks andy i guess there's there's not
a great deal of surprise for council in
the areas that you've identified
certainly with three waters we know that
we're
uh paddling in the same walk as other
councils they're around the capital
projects
it is certainly an issue that staff have
gone to some length
uh to make sure that we are aware of um
going into it and uh being constantly
updated on as well and we've had to bear
that in mind
as we've put together the um the
long-term plan for consultation so
thank you for your comments and thank
you for for working with our staff to
get
uh get the opinion through in time we
appreciate it
pleasure councillors there are four
recommendations i'm looking for a move
and a second to please councillor arnold
and councillor sopa thank you it's open
for questions or comments
councillor clark thank you thank you
champ um
i just want to signal with my colleagues
that i'm opposed to the
uh portion of the long term plan that
has the
museum project out to 2026.
i expected to accept the degree of work
that staff have put in this has been a
massive document
but i'm getting a wide range of
committee feedback
regarding the project being too far out
into the future currently proposed
for a five and a half year period where
the
report we got in 2020 suggested it was a
three-year project
i accept this plan is probably going to
be adopted today and so my
reason for being an opposition is the
wish to prompt rate payers
and organizations in our communities
that have said to me that they are
not happy about the museum and the
eyesight
um being closed for that period of time
to come forward and make some
some presentation to the uh consultation
process
putting aside the scope issue which is
something that counselor pontia raised
the other day about
we may end up having some feedback that
maybe
option c is not the preferred option for
the committee
and putting aside the affordability
issue which orders uh recently just just
touched on
um the issue of deliverable
deliverability is the
uh and the timeframes is the issue for
me and so um
while staff and colleagues i guess have
spoken on all three of these issues
um my viewers are getting to the core of
this issue about the museum and how long
it should take and how much lead in time
we need
it's a little bit i guess like peeling
an onion every time i remove a layer
um it just seems to have another layer
my eyes weep every every single time i
do it
um just a quick reflection back with
your blessing chair um about the history
of this museum
back in 2011 which is 10 years ago the
long term player had a commitment
from museum redevelopment um
and to quote it it set a museum
redevelopment opportunity to transform
the facility into a first class regional
museum unfortunately that that wasn't
delivered and we've had a second go
since then
we've obviously had a series of
earthquake prime building status reports
and that led to the
icc removing the staff and the museum
closing
we've also had the tim walker report
which was extensive
but that was never tabled by smag with
icc so that's
left it in sorta limbo for quite some
time and the museum's been close to
three years
and there is some degree of skepticism
in the community around
um iwaka two here as well so just
leading into this long term plan i guess
there's two issues that drive my
opposition one is that we did an
invocable levels of service research
document back in
august 2020 so that spoke to
key stakeholder groups in the community
and about roughly 800 people were
telephoned
and it was an interesting report because
in the summary on page five
it says strengthen and develop the
museum was the top priority for
for the people in the community that
rated 50 percent next one down was the
water tower at 29
alternative waters supply 27 and the
list just went further down
so that gave a really really strong
message later in the same year 2020 we
had a community engagement process
on the priority prioritization and i was
partied to some of those um
face-to-face sessions we had and the
museum was absolutely the top priority
so um when i consider the options that
we've got i consider we have adequate
funding
um there's been issues thrown up about
the work capacity of industries to
deliver
a big project like this i've had
feedback from two large construction
firms
that they have capacity to do the work
the issue of our ability to recruit a
project manager is still there
and on the issue of the collection
storage i've been able to identify there
is 800 square meters
of atmospherically controlled space
potentially available for sensitive
artifacts
within the city and so i think that some
of those
layers of the onion are
i guess are roadblocks i guess that we
should we should bring that project
forward
and the last couple things i'd just like
to contribute is that there is a degree
of
skepticism within our community around
our ability to
um to deliver projects uh two good
examples of was the water tower that was
approved by this council in 2018 and to
date
hasn't been delivered and the protracted
time that we took to get the chinese
garden over the line
i accept that we have a new elt group
and i accept that they're
they've got an enthusiasm but in the
last
review that we did of the long term plan
in 2018 we had five projects in the
first four years
none of those have been finalized in
fact all but one of them hasn't even
been started
and so i guess there's a degree of
skepticism
in the community that we should have
built the long-term plan
around the museum and made everything
secondary to our ability to deliver that
so based on that i won't support
only on the assumption that i want the
community to come forward and have their
voice because they keep coming to me but
i can't deal with it
on a council by council basis it just
needs to be
it needs to come through this process
thanks counselor clark just
by way of clarification though even
though you've expressed an opposition
you are open to hearing
what comes in the public comments sorry
i should have should have said that um
and certainly after the consultation
process if if the outcome is
option c or b or d and it's a six year
project then that's the process yeah i
certainly will not be any opposition to
that once we've done our consultation
the ball is now back in the community
court i agree
and and thanks for provoking the
discussion which hopefully members of
the community
uh respond to it is worth noting just
before i come to you councillor craic it
is worth noting that
the two previous attempts to have the
redevelopment
project undertaken smag
itself was looking to facilitate
a a joint project between
three councils and other organizations
whereas in this instance it
will certainly talk to its partners but
the city council is in
a position where it can drive the
project so i guess that's one of the
differences that should help
get it across the board and we're
looking at more than the four and a half
million that
was originally premised but promised in
the first
uh long-term plan but um but thanks for
making the call
just make one one other observation
which i think rhiannon raised at our
last meeting
was that this this um roadmap is now
talking about years as calendar years as
opposed to financial years
and that's that's changed the dialogue a
little bit true
so to clarify councillors yes for the
public so as to
simplify the the roadmap is talking
about calendar years but that does not
change
any of the financial modeling underneath
has just simplified it for the purposes
of communication
yep thank you thanks councillor crackit
oh thank you mr chair
i'm actually with councillor clark on
this one but not an opposition
just in that feedback is just of the
utmost importance on this
um as he stated our community has told
us that they're really unhappy with the
number of closures across the city and
they have been
for a while and while we're in
conjunction with our skilled officers
and industry specialists
formed the plan that we're currently
calling our roadmap to renewal so
opening those facilities and
strengthening those facilities and
getting those facilities back
up and running as it's been stated this
ltp is really ambitious
uh the size of our capital works project
is quite extensive
uh it's the largest that we've seen in
an extremely long time
my concern is to our community i do not
want to
over promise and under deliver these
projects
as we have had in the past a history of
doing that
while we might have our differences of
opinion
as individual councillors as you've seen
here with councillor clark today
so well individuals in our community and
it's really important to respect those
opinions
and that's why throughout this process
um
this council to have arrived at this
roadmap to renewal
has been united in our approach of what
we want to take out to the community
to get those discussions uh started
um it's ambitious right now it's
important that we get the feedback
the feedback and having that dialogue is
what's most important
and i'm happy to uh confirm
the recommendations in the report and um
move those mr chair
thanks do we have a movie
sorry you were there that's right thank
you my apologies counselor
uh councillor scout thank you
um i can only endorse councillors
clark's comments really in the sense
of the homework he's done the passion
that he's given um on this particular
project which is dear to his heart and
dear to
all our hearts to be honest and it's
clear that
over time for whatever reason we haven't
been able to get
this one across the line and councillor
clark is correct there is a massive
community expectation i have a massive
respect also for erin and the work that
she's done around not just this project
but all the projects
but i guess here in the question for you
is in flexibility there's three things
been outlined really that council
clark's
alluded to um today um in the sense of
and i guess they're moving targets in
the
procurement of a obviously a project
manager obviously someone who can build
the thing
and obviously the um the storage
facility but i think the concern for all
of us if we're honest with ourselves is
just that
at miss generation where we haven't had
a museum and it seems a long
way out that 2026. all i'm asking is
is it possible within that flexibility
line given where the current building is
that we could
well we i know you'll continue to look
at it but we need some encouragement i
guess
and our community certainly does because
i can tell you now
going out to community consultation it
will be
very strong in favor of the museum i
would imagine
i would imagine i'm very careful
chairman could you be very careful and
make sure the questions go through me
rather than director erin
oh certainly i'll go through you in the
bank you might flick to erin well i
might not need to
oh and i'd like you to if you would but
anyway um
i'll just finish thanks so i fully
endorse uh council clerks i think
if there's any way we can move this
particular project forward
any possible way uh then i think we
should put all our energy into it
thank you councillor let me start
answering your question with firstly i
think we should wait to hear what it is
that people have to say
rather than jumping to conclusions
secondly the answer is yes
you can change timetables but the
question that the council will have to
deal with then is what do you shift out
because for one thing to come in
something else is going to have to go up
because it's
only so much debt that we're able to to
raise
to be able to carry out the projects
we've been made aware of
you know potential issues around uh
resourcing
um obviously we're all acutely aware and
and none more than me of how long this
project's taken
we were getting somewhere and then the
stadium fell over
that's not a pointed comment um
we we put the project on the back burner
because the community could only afford
so much and we recognize the value of
what needed to happen
we re-scoped it but in the meantime
the operation and
governance of smag has come under review
which actually glass outfall leaves us
in a much better position to get the
project going forward so like i say yeah
timelines can change but it's a game of
tetris and we're gonna have to figure
out what else
we can shift out in order to be able to
afford that i can see you looking and
i'll go to her just to check to see
that i'm right but did you hear what i
said i did so
i'll set a test later erin is there
anything i've missed
low seat thank you mr chair
um i think i'd just reiterate the
comment that was made
um the council and the community can
decide on a program
and frankly council officers will do
their darndest to deliver it
um but that being said it's already been
noted that this is a big step
up for us we haven't been in a position
where we have been delivering capital
programs with this number of projects
and this number of value
the maturity in doing that the team
to do that doesn't come from nowhere and
we are in a position where we need to
put together a team to do that at a time
where the rest of the country is already
trying to compete with us for those
those same resources
so obviously we'll go out to the
community we'll
see where they feel those priorities sit
but to reiterate the point made if we
actually want to have something that we
think we have our best
chance of delivering on and improving
our reputation
as delivering for our community then we
want a program that we think is
realistic and if the museum comes in
then then what else pushes out
thanks erin um it's also worth
noting first of all the comments that
andy made
in the audit opinion around risk
and observers of the news over the
weekend will notice that
carter holt harvey is starting to hold
back on timber which is going to affect
some activity in the construction area
uh becks then councillor pottinger
thanks chair
i was just going to reiterate what the
auditor said about the capital works
program that we've already got in the
ltp
it's extensive it's full and part of
that is because we've
already made some decisions to push
ahead with some projects
and we've done that despite the fact
that the museum as councillor clark
said came back as the priority in the
community feedback that's already been
done
and i've just been thinking about the
2018 ltp
where we had those five projects where
none of them have actually happened
and i feel like if we're not careful we
might make the same mistake again
and that we front load our ltp with too
many things and then because we're
trying to do too much we don't actually
achieve anything
so i'm really interested to hear
feedback from the community
i would really encourage the community
to think about if
the museum is a priority and they would
like that moved forward
what things they would like to see us
pushing out
or changing in the ltp so that we can do
that if it is humanly possible um
and i'd really encourage the community
to give us feedback
whether it's for or against or a little
bit for and a little bit or a little bit
against because sometimes i think we
only encourage the
feedback against things in the ltp but i
think it's really good to hear
feedback from people who um
are happy with what's in there or happy
with parts of what is in there
and i'd also just you know i'm a big
advocate for community engagement and i
think we've got a great community
engagement plan
for this ltp as long as covert doesn't
muck it up again like it did last time
um but i think we also have to remember
that the feedback we get from the
community is only one part of the
information that we have to use when
we're making decisions
um we still have to consider all of the
other parts of the information that we
receive including the professional and
staff advice
and those kinds of things and i think
that we all have to bear that in mind as
we go through the decision-making
or the consultation process and the
decision-making process as a result of
that
thanks councillor amundsen uh councillor
partner thank you chair
look at 10 years looking at long-term
plans
and looking at the potential museum
redevelopment
i am i finally have confidence
that we are on the we have the right
roadmap to get this done
um the way it's been strategically put
um and i really don't know if i can't
understand the fuss
before consultation but you know
people are entitled to the views my my
view
is about is the importance of getting
this project
right because i believe looking to the
future generations
is more important than just getting a
rush job done
for current generations and i'm worried
a wee bit of
political interference that will
interfere with this long-term
ideal of of of creating something very
special that
in 50 years time when we're not here
people go wow
they actually took the time to get that
right
and they didn't just rush it through to
tick a box
so look i'm happy with the timeline
because i'm purely about quality and
what's going to be for our future
generations and i can see
that we have the right plan for that so
that's where i sit
and i again i welcome the consultation
thank you councillor soper
thank you mr chair um it won't come as a
surprise to anyone that i'm a great
believer in the democratic process
and in the and in the invitation we make
to
air public through consultation
documents to give us the feedback
so i'm also um very much committed to
the importance of keeping an
open mind at all times throughout my
political life both
centrally and locally that is an
extremely important aspect
so i'm not going to make any
any value judgments at the moment except
to say that we have
something to go out to consultation that
we are seriously
asking the public to give us feedback on
and i really do urge from a long career
in listening to
submissions that if if members of our
public
are going to give us feedback and that
feedback comes down to
we would like changes in the timing of
what's proposed
that they do give us an idea of what
they would like moved out delayed
held up for a long length of time what
they are prepared to give up
in order to change timings and also
what rate increase they would see as
acceptable we are in very tight
financial margins
a great deal of planning has gone into
what's presented
if people do want to give us the idea
that things should be moved around
can they give us some quite detailed
input not just a simple no we don't like
that particular aspect but we do really
like the idea of moving that forward
and we would be prepared for a slight
rate and increase to to achieve that
that that would be very helpful to us um
and since there has now been quite a bit
of conversation on
on how important consultation is i do
just say to the
to the public it is really important to
give us your detailed
opinions thank you
thank you any other questions or
comments your worship
thank you mr chair the um
there's a lot of misinformation uh
rattling around an issue like this and
one of them is
that this generation may not have the
benefits of a museum
but i take little decline to the museum
regularly
it's the maritime museum and love which
is
our port one of our most valuable assets
and the tourism
factor also comes into play i was on a
board in auckland and we were
testing where tourists actually arrived
the gateway to new zealand
and it's clearly the museum that's where
they look at a
nation's culture where they look at
how the people live and and
want to experience what they have
come across and so i'm backing
in this case consultation as well
thank you worship look thank you
councillors for the discussion
because i think glass half of what we've
done is shine a light
on an issue that we know has been at the
forefront of people's minds
through pre-consultation and certainly
through the previous
um ltp but it's also given us a chance
to highlight for the media and those in
attendance what some of the issues are
around it as well
so that's been really useful i thank you
for that
it's been moved and seconded councillors
i'll now put the motion all in favor
against councillor clark would you like
your vote recorded thank you
thank you okay councillors
uh that concludes everything for the
extraordinary uh performance policy and
partnerships committee so
i'll declare it closed and we will start
the extraordinary council meeting in
just a moment
andy are you sticking around for that um
you wish i think i've heard you you've
had your couple
if you've got stuff to do that's that's
fine essentially we're going through the
process of confirming what we've just
been
talking about so okay so i'll take my
leave in thanks
thank you very much for your time okay
thank you bye
thank you
you worship enjoy
oh and i forgot to mention the riverton
museum
where you play a formidable role it's a
brilliant little movie and there's also
hey wakatooya your worship
and i'm going to be in the black panther
revival movement yes which i'm really
looking forward to
this is tuesday
right we've obviously got a quorum no
problems
declared a meeting
[Music]
is andy not staying no he's not staying
your worship
so there being uh apologies from
councillor abbott
move the apology your worship uh and and
with lindsey mckenzie as well you
worship i'm happy to second that
thank you it's been moved and seconded
any discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
means carried
move on to the interest register no
changes there thank you
consider items in the public agenda
report of and adoption
oh yes and sorry my nose is
thank you consider the items on the
public agenda the report and adoption of
the long-term plan
consultation
document and supplementary report
material
rihanna you're taking us through this
again
thank you your worship so this is now
just the opportunity to formally adopt
all of those materials just discussed
and confirmed
at the last meeting the performance
policy and partnerships committee
prior to consultation commencing
tomorrow
you councillor thank you worship uh look
i'm happy to move the
through recommendations i know that
recommendation too we've not only gone
through the alphabet but there are a few
letters we've managed to double up on as
well
which is spectacular rhiannon i think
it's the first time we've done it
while that's a light-hearted comment um
i have
said to people over the past couple of
months you know starting from
towards the end of last year that i feel
that this is the most
engaged council has been going through
a long-term plan process and getting
ready for what it is that we take out
for consultation and bearing in mind
that we've had to go through all that at
the same time as we've been dealing with
the dia
issues is is no mean feat for for us as
councillors but also for the staff
who have an enormous amount of work that
they've had to do to
prepare first of all what it is for
pre-consultation
then prepare what it is that we want to
take out for consultation and we're
actually
halfway through you know and and the
time frames
are tight admittedly between when we've
completed that consultation process
gone through the hearings and go through
the decision-making process
with that those two joys uh yet to come
but thank you very much rhiannon
and and everybody that you've been
working with uh michael
uh claire uh for your leadership over
this process as well
to get us to this point with the method
of engagement that we've had as a
council
is is no mean feat and it is appreciated
thank you worship
thank any you comments
questions
i'll second those thank you
got a mover in secondary
but we already had one haven't we
which one would you prefer councillors
we've got two seconds
sort of
there'd be no further discussion i'll
put it to the vote
i'm
the end of the meeting and we now have a
workshop
all right to clear the meeting closed
the night
you